قد يظن البعض ان التضارب الازلي لدى
الفتيات بين الطموح المهني وحلم تاسيس
اسره يقتصر على العالم العربي والمجتمعات
المحافظه لكن التضارب ورغم كل مظاهر
التقدم هو في الواقع ازمه نسائيه عالميه
الامريكيه اظهرت ان اكثر من 60% من النساء
حول العالم
يتخلينا بدرجه من الدرجات عن الطموح
المهني لاجل الزواج وتكوين اسره الرقم
البارز هو 19% من النساء لا يكترثن اصلا
للموضوع المهني لا طموح لديهننا في هذا
المجال اما اللواتي يعطينا الاولويه
للطموح المهني فهي بنسبه مماثله تقريبا
20%
ورغم كل التقدم في الانماط الاجتماعيه بما
في ذلك في الغرب ما زالت طموح المهني
وتحقيق النجاح في الوظيفه يكلف المراه
الكثير وذلك بحسب جامعه كامريجا
البريطانيه وكالعاده حياه المراه صعبه
ويتعين عليها ان تحدد اولوياتها واذا
اختارت الوظيفه فهذا لا يعفيها ابدا من
مهامها العائليه لصباح العربيه الريان
الظاهر